what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we actually have a lot of things
to talk about of course including
spider-man no way home when that second
trailer should be coming out we've also
had a pretty big leaked photo from
spider-man no way home come out showing
the sinister six kind of showing us a
scene that is going to take place and to
top it all off today we got a tease of a
possible deadpool and hulk team up which
is something completely out of left
field but something that i'm sure many
many fans would really really love to
see so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos and let's
dive into today's topics the first one
of course the big question that
everybody has been asking when are we
going to be getting that second
spider-man noah home trailer i knew as
soon as we got the first trailer
immediately after people were going to
be asking where's the second one because
i knew we weren't going to see any signs
of tobey maguire or andrew garfield in
the first trailer i'm actually very
surprised that they showed alfred
molina's doc ock and they showed a
pumpkin bomb i didn't actually think
that they would tease these in the very
first teaser trailer but they did and it
was fantastic now of course since they
did that people are looking to the
second trailer to show us the other two
spiderman and it looks like we don't
have to wait that much longer as we have
news that the second trailer could be
hitting in november now this news is
coming from daniel rpk he posted this to
twitter yesterday and for those of you
who don't know daniel rpk he is very
very accurate with when trailers are
going to be released his track record
for when trailers for movies are going
to be released is pretty spot on and he
was pretty accurate about the first
trailer as well so this is most likely
when we are going to be getting that
second full official trailer from sony
for spider-man no way home now will it
show the other two spider-men that
remains to be seen i have heard that
they are going to show them in a trailer
towards the latter half of marketing for
the film and that could mean the
official trailer that could mean a third
trailer but considering the fact that
they actually did tease alfred molina's
doc ock they showed a pumpkin bomb they
teased electro the lizard sandman i'm
going to assume that they're really
going to show these characters in the
next trailer they're also going to
explain how they got there and obviously
that's going to be a multiversal effect
of whatever spell that doctor strange
did so while they are talking about in
the official trailer how all of these
villains have made it into this universe
i wouldn't be surprised if they said oh
but something else also came some good
came and that good comes in the form of
two other spider-men i could definitely
see this happening a very very quick
tease perhaps a shot of like three
different spider webs shooting from a
scene or just a quick shot of the three
spider-man together if we honestly got
the meme of all three of them pointed
together and that's all we got in any
trailer leading up to the movie i would
be perfectly fine with that but it does
look like that trailer is going to be
coming in november so we don't have that
much longer to wait so hopefully we see
the two other spider-man in this trailer
very soon now speaking of all of the
villains moving on to the next topic the
sinister six and a leaked photo that has
been going around now originally a while
ago i'm talking months ago there were
some photos going around of doc ock
after melinda's doc ock jamie foxx's
electro and willem dafoe's norman
osborne now we didn't really know the
context of these leaked photos before
and many people thought they were fake
but as it turns out they're true they're
real photos but again the context of
them was not known until now as it turns
out it looks like these old photos are
from a scene of where the villains are
inside their prison cells in the sanctum
or wherever dr strange is seemingly
keeping them and now we have a leaked
photo that is pre-cgi so pre-any visual
effects done to it that shows these
villains in prison cells in the sanctum
and it matches with the photos that
we've had in the past now i can't show
this photo because it's copyright and of
course there is always a chance that
it's not real people out there are
trolling a lot right now but many people
have said that it is indeed real and it
does match up with the other photos that
we've seen before and i personally know
that this scene is a direct scene from
spider-man no way home i've done a
couple of videos in the past talking
about a plot leak that i've heard has
been confirmed to be true a couple of
insiders told me about this plot leak
they said that pretty much everything in
the plot leak is real and this scene
happens in that plot leak if you have
not read that plot leak this is what it
says about this particular scene it
starts off by talking about what we kind
of saw in the trailer peter's life is
ruined after his identity was revealed
by mysterio he's facing trial and then
he goes to doctor strange and he asks
him to cast a spell to make everyone
forget that he is spider-man and keep in
mind this was posted like months before
we got the official trailer so this is
proven to be true and it goes on to say
something goes wrong with the spell and
they break reality and bring five
spider-man villains of other dimensions
to the mcu green goblin from spider-man
1 dog ock from spider-man 2 the sandman
from spider-man 3 the lizard from the
amazing spider-man and electro from the
amazing spider-man 2. norman osborne is
talking to the others asking what is the
last thing that they remember and they
all say that spider-man killed them with
the exception of sandman now here's
where we get the scene dr strange wants
to take them back to their original
dimensions but the villains feared that
returning would mean that they would
return to the exact same spot where they
came from meaning they would die and
here's the really important part norman
osborne manipulates peter into freeing
them making him feel guilty for their
deaths peter fights doctor strange and
breaks the key which is a cube which we
have seen in the trailer that held them
captive and the villains are now free so
what this tells us is that doctor
strange is holding them in some type of
prison he has some sort of cells prison
cells magical cells whatever you want to
call it holding them there and that is
the new leaked photo going around right
now and again it does include the leaked
pictures that we have seen in the past
so this new leaked photo is of this
scene the villains in their cells and
the interesting thing is that it does
look like they're in the sanctum in fact
it looks like they're in the exact same
spot where doctor strange performs the
spell in the trailer now in the trailer
around doctor strange and peter during
that moment we can see that everything
is kind of broken down and crumbles this
could be clever editing for the trailer
perhaps everything is fine but the
sinister six breaking out actually
caused some havoc and destruction and
that's what leads to some of this stuff
falling apart now of course it's always
hard to tell with marvel trailers
because they do things like this to
throw us off which is actually really
nice we don't find out everything from
the trailer because they're kind of
secretive with it but i'm gonna say this
is what's happening this leaked photo is
of the villains and their cells peter
and doctor strange fight and they
accidentally free them and the villains
cause a little bit of destruction before
they leave out into new york city and
honestly that's going to be a super
awesome spider-man scene all of these
different villains from different
universes coming into our main mcu and
if that wasn't enough to get you excited
about the future of the mcu today mark
ruffalo is seemingly teasing something
going on between the hulk and deadpool
mark ruffalo posted a picture to
instagram about four hours ago of him
and ryan reynolds laying on the ground
together next to them is a bin and on
the top of that bin we see a deadpool
sticker and a hulk sticker now this is
definitely a huge tease whether or not
this means something we don't really
know at this point in time a certain
post-credit scene has recently told us
that mark ruffalo is still around and we
know that he's going to be in she-hulk
we also know that deadpool 3 is not too
far away kevin feige said that they
already have a release date planned for
deadpool 3 and ryan reynolds has said
that he works on the script for deadpool
3 every single day could we perhaps see
the hulk in deadpool 3 kind of like how
we saw the juggernaut in deadpool 2.
deadpool breaking the 4th wall says that
he's a huge fan of juggernaut big fan of
him in the comics could we get a similar
situation here with the hulk i really
really hope so and i hope we get the old
original hulk like a beefy super angry
hulk now keep in mind this photo is most
likely from the movie the atom project
which both ryan reynolds and mark
ruffalo are going to be in however they
don't really have a reason to show a
deadpool and hulk sticker on there
they're definitely teasing us now
whether or not that's actually something
that's going to happen or not we'll have
to wait and see however like i said ryan
reynolds has been working on the script
for deadpool 3 every day for a while and
if he was in a movie with mark ruffalo
there is a chance that he perhaps did
write the hulk into deadpool 3 since he
was around the hulk all the time and
luckily we don't have that much longer
to wait for deadpool 3 because it looks
like production on that is going to be
starting pretty soon and since it
already has a release date according to
kevin feige that means the movie
shouldn't be more than two years away
and when it finally does come out i
personally really really hope that the
hulk is in deadpool 3 but let me know
what you think about all of this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and for a live update you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof